Kevin Sorbo's time in the spotlight has diminished
since his Hercules days, but if you think
you've seen him around lately, you might just
be right.
Keep watching to see what he's been up to!
In 2012, Sorbo published a book containing
some shocking revelations.
In the later seasons of Hercules: The Legendary
Journeys, which aired from 1994 to 1999, viewers
started to notice a shift away from the title
character and onto the shoulders of other
stars.
No one knew why there was a sudden flood of
guest stars, and it wasn't until Sorbo published
his book that fans learned the truth: in 1997,
he suffered three strokes as the result of
an aneurysm.
True Strength: My Journey from Hercules to
Mere Mortal How Nearly Dying Saved My Life
is the story of just what happened to Sorbo.
He was in the middle of a promotional tour
for Kull the Conqueror when he started to
feel some odd sensations in his left hand
and arm, but doctors brushed it off.
The pain worsened during a workout, and he
went to his chiropractor.
After driving home, he started suffering all
the symptoms of a stroke.
It was then that doctors discovered and removed
the aneurysm that was blocking blood flow
to his arm.
After returning to the Hercules set, Sorbo
endured aftereffects like fatigue, depression,
and anxiety attacks.
He still suffers from nerve damage, residual
pain, the occasional migraine, and a ten percent
loss of vision, and he says that the experience
made him realize what was truly important
to him: his wife and his faith.
It also made him want to share his story in
the hopes of helping others through similar
experiences.
"We are survivors and we should never, ever
give up."
In 2014, fantasy fans got to see Sorbo don
his medieval gear once again with the release
of Mythica: A Quest for Heroes, his second
collaboration with the production company
Arrowstorm.
When he was approached to read the script,
he was absolutely and unconditionally on board,
even though he was playing the wizard rather
than the warrior this time around.
More Mythica movies followed, with The Darkspore
and The Necromancer arriving in 2015, and
then The Iron Crown and The Godslayer in 2016.
When Sorbo spoke with Geek Dad in 2015, he
acknowledged that while his role as the heroine's
mentor was limited in the initial film, he
was going to play a bigger part as the story
went on.
When he was asked why fantasy had become his
go-to genre, he admitted,
"Love that world.
No rules in the fantasy world.
Writers can do what they want and make it
come to life.
Just fun to be a part of the fantasy."
Sorbo became famous for his portrayal of a
legendary character, and in 2017 news broke
that he'd soon be associated with another
famous franchise.
When it was first revealed that he would be
playing a recurring character on The CW's
Supergirl, he was simply described as one
of the show's many bad guys.
The mystery surrounding just who he was going
to portray built for more than a month.
That's practically forever in internet time,
but finally the studio eventually confirmed
that he'd be stepping into the boots of Mon-El's
father, Lar Gand.
Sorbo ended up appearing in a three-episode
arc, with former Lois Lane Teri Hatcher playing
his wife.
In an interview with Entertainment Tonight,
he revealed that if things had gone a little
differently back in 1993, he would've ended
up playing Superman opposite Hatcher in Lois
& Clark: The New Adventures of Superman.
But, alas, that part ultimately went to Dean
Cain instead.
Sorbo is a devout Christian, and recent years
have seen him frequently turning his attention
to faith-based films.
In 2014's God's Not Dead, he stars as an atheist
professor who challenges his students' views
on the existence of God.
"God.
Is.
Dead."
In 2014, he was also in Revelation Road: The
Black Rider, a tale about what's left after
the Rapture, and Let the Lion Roar, in which
he played Reformation leader John Calvin.
He even played Joseph in 2016's Joseph and
Mary, a retelling of one of the Bible's most
well-known stories.
In a 2016 interview with Gospel Herald, he
spoke about why he thought bringing faith-based
films to the big screen was important:
"I think that most people would agree that
faith-based movies back in the '70s, '80s,
and even the '90s were very cheesy, poorly
written, and poorly acted.
A lot of people were turned off by them, because
they were also too preachy.
We live in a world where people don't want
to be told what to believe in and what not
to believe in.
You have to walk a fine line to hold an audience."
Sorbo shows no sign of slowing down, even
teaming up with Fox News' Sean Hannity for
Let There be Light, which is about an atheist
who has a near-death experience.
Since 1997, Sorbo has been involved with almost
every aspect of a charity called "A World
Fit For Kids!"
As a celebrity spokesperson, he's spoken out
about things like the nationwide drop-out
rate for schools and childhood obesity, pushing
to get A World Fit For Kids! to go outside
of California and into other parts of the
country.
At its heart, the charity is an after-school
program that touches on everything from physical
fitness, to training teens to become mentors
for younger children, to preparing kids for
what they're going to be confronted with once
they reach the working world.
"All kids deserve that kind of encouragement,
but the reality is, most don't get it.
That's why I'm involved with A World Fit for
Kids."
Sorbo has headed up fundraisers and participated
in public service announcements about issues
like providing workplace mentors to students
interested in pursuing their dreams.
In 2005, he took on another charity role as
the spokesperson for the Afterschool Alliance,
an organization dedicated to providing safe
and educational programs for students.
So even if you haven't seen much of Sorbo's
recent film and TV appearances, he's still
been working steadily in whatever capacity
he's passionate about.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.